schock für 209 passagiere an bord von
condor flug de 14 39 von lanzarote nach
hamburg kurz nach dem start schlagen
funken aus dem triebwerk mehrere laute
knallgeräusche sind zu hören die
maschine muss auf der benachbarten insel
fuerteventura notlanden die 23 jahre
alte boeing 757 war freitag um 13 58 auf
dem flughafen von arrecife gestartet auf
einer webcam aufnahme des flughafens ist
zu hören laute knallgeräusche nur 17
sekunden später
die ursache für knall und funkenflug ist
noch unklar möglich wäre ein kompressor
schaden dafür sprechen die vielen lauten
knallgeräusche aber auch ein vogelschlag
die maschine wird jetzt von technikern
untersucht die passagiere wurden in
hotels untergebracht sollen am samstag
mit einer ersatzmaschine nach hause
geflogen werden